Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件目前正在发生的令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有由Lisa本人直接提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢得与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导课程。想了解更多吗？当然想。前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。我是Marianne Trent博士，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。
I am Dr. Marianne Trent. I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Thank you so much for joining me today. Today's sort of a special request, sort of plug the gap, help with this kind of where I'm at right now episode. So if you are currently striving to be an aspiring clinical psychologist, you might well know that we are in the middle of application notification season about whether you are being called to interview this year. So this episode is going live on Monday the 13th of March 2023 and that is quite an important week because on the 17th of March, also known as St Patrick's Day, that is the deadline for all of the courses to have notified their applicants whether they're going to be offering them an interview or not this year. So if you're
我是Marianne Trent博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。非常感谢大家今天的收听。今天这期节目算是一个特别请求，旨在填补空白，帮助大家了解我目前的处境。如果你现在正努力成为一名临床心理学家，你可能很清楚我们正处于申请通知季，即今年是否会收到面试邀请。这期节目在2023年3月13日星期一发布，这是一个非常重要的星期，因为3月17日，也就是圣帕特里克节，是所有课程通知申请者今年是否提供面试机会的截止日期。所以如果你
listening to this and you don't yet know whether you're getting an interview, then you've got until Friday. So after that point, hopefully you will know and you won't need to keep refreshing and scrolling and busying yourself and wondering and hoping unless of course you're on the reserve list in which case things probably will continue in that vein for a while for you until those interviews for your course that you're on the reserve list for have passed. So this week has been tricky for some and you know euphoric for others and sometimes a bit of a mixed bag as well sometimes people were told a no thanks not yet one day to then get a course offer of an interview or a course offer for a reserve place the next day or maybe you know one of each you know um
正在听这期节目，且还不知道自己是否获得了面试机会，那么你还有到周五的时间。在那之后，希望你就能知晓结果，不必再不断刷新、滚动页面、忙碌奔波、心怀忐忑和希望了。当然，除非你在候补名单上，那样的话，在你所申请课程的面试结束之前，这种情况可能会持续一段时间。所以这一周对一些人来说很棘手，对另一些人来说则欣喜若狂，有时也是喜忧参半。有时人们先是被告知“不，谢谢，还不是时候”，结果第二天就收到了面试邀请或候补名额，或者可能两者都有，
a no thanks not yet an interview and a reserve place and that's you know that's a lot of it's a lot of stuff to try and get your head around so if this is where you're at right now but of course you might be listening to this in years to come when it is your time and when this is relevant for you because the beauty of podcasts and youtube if you've never been onto my youtube channel um dr marianne trent it's probably time that you did it's probably time that you check that out and subscribed um so yeah the beauty of this is that it's going to hang around so that it will be there when you need it and when it will resonate with you the most. I have got a few more podcast episodes already in the can and ready to
一个“不，谢谢，还不是时候”、一个面试邀请和一个候补名额，这确实让人难以消化。所以如果你现在正处于这个阶段，当然，你可能是在未来的某一年听到这期节目，那时这正是你所经历的，也是与你相关的。因为播客和YouTube的魅力在于——如果你从未去过我的YouTube频道“Dr. Marianne Trent”，现在可能是时候去看看并订阅了——是的，它的魅力在于它会一直存在，当你需要它并产生共鸣时，它就在那里。我已经录制好了几期播客，准备
roll and they are guest interviews but I thought that it seemed really important for us to do some stuff that's about the right now. So I decided to hastily record this because people have been contacting me kind of amazed really about the number of applicants that the courses are telling them have applied this year. So I thought it might be useful to have a little bit of a look at some of the data from previous years. So let's have a look at that together. So it seems a good place to start with the pre-pandemic stats. So those that we are looking at right now on YouTube, or I'll talk you through them if you're listening on podcast, are from 2019, for 2019 entry.
发布，它们是嘉宾访谈，但我认为做一些关于“当下”的内容非常重要。所以我决定匆忙录制这一期，因为人们一直在联系我，对今年课程申请人数之多感到非常惊讶。所以我认为回顾一下往年的数据可能会很有用。让我们一起来看看。从疫情前的统计数据开始似乎是个不错的选择。所以我们现在在YouTube上看到的，或者如果你在听播客我会为你讲解的，是2019年入学的数据。
So the year that people actually applied for that would have been 2018. So the deadline would have been December 2018. So that year, there were 614 places, and there were 4054 applicants. So that gave a success rate of getting a place of 15%. Although of course, you know, people will have probably had interviews at multiple courses so um that that success rate is skewed a little bit that's sort of assuming that each applicant only is offered one place um so yes that's you know somebody might have had potentially four offers and so their success rate would have been you know 100% but yeah this is done as as all of the applicants and you know there's only so many courses to go around so that's where they get the
人们实际申请的那一年应该是2018年。所以截止日期应该是2018年12月。那一年有614个名额，有4054名申请者。这使得获得名额的成功率为15%。当然，人们可能在多个课程中获得了面试机会，所以这个成功率被稍微扭曲了，这假设每个申请者只被提供一个名额。所以是的，有人可能潜在地获得了四个录取通知，那么他们的成功率就是100%。但这是按所有申请者计算的，名额有限，这就是他们得出
15% from. Let's go on now to have a look at the people who would have started their training in September 2020 so that would have been kind of in the middle of the pandemic, wouldn't it? They would have applied perhaps when they just started to hear whisperings about COVID-19, which would have been December 2019. So then there was 4,225 applicants for 770 places. So you can see that the success rate for them was 18%. That's a whopping increase of 25.4 places compared to the previous year, but only a 4.21 increase on applicants that year, which meant that there was effectively a success rate of 18% that year. Let's have a quick look at the entry for 2021. So again people would have applied
15%的原因。现在让我们来看看那些在2020年9月开始培训的人，那应该是在疫情期间，对吧？他们申请时可能刚刚开始听到关于COVID-19的风声，那是在2019年12月。当时有4225名申请者争夺770个名额。所以你可以看到他们的成功率是18%。与前一年相比，名额增加了25.4%，但申请人数仅增加了4.21%，这意味着那年的实际成功率为18%。让我们快速看一下2021年的入学情况。同样，人们是在
during the pandemic. They would have applied by December 2020 ready to start in September 2021. So that year there were 979 places available. There were 4,544 applicants that made a success rate of 22%. So let's look at the percentage increase then. So that was an absolute bonzer, just over 27% increase in places available and only a 7.55% increase in numbers of applicants that year, which made the success rate 22%, which seems a lot nicer, but of course can still be brutal, absolutely brutal. We're going to take a short break here and then I'll be back and we'll discuss some more stats. So many things that you can try. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. Okay, welcome back um do remember that the clinical psychologist collective books
疫情期间申请的。他们必须在2020年12月前申请，以便在2021年9月入学。那一年有979个名额，有4544名申请者，成功率为22%。让我们看看百分比增长。这是一个巨大的飞跃，名额增加了超过27%，而申请人数仅增加了7.55%，这使得成功率达到22%，看起来好多了，但当然仍然可能非常残酷。我们在这里休息一下，回来后我们将讨论更多统计数据。有很多你可以尝试的事情。《有抱负的心理学家集体》。《有抱负的心理学家集体》。好的，欢迎回来。请记住，《临床心理学家集体》书籍
and the aspiring psychologist collective books can be really useful for helping you to build skills and confidence in talking about your reflections which can be really really useful for you to be able to do during interviews and of course we do lots of stuff around that in the membership as well and people are saying really lovely things saying that they just feel that their development has come on leaps and bounds and people have been getting interviews so if you have an interview and you'd welcome some extra development skills coaching confidence boosting then do check out the aspiring psychologist membership okay so in the first half we were looking at some stats from the previous years provided by the clearinghouse website so
和《有抱负的心理学家集体》书籍对于帮助你建立技能和自信，谈论你的反思非常有帮助，这在面试中非常有用。当然，我们在会员计划中也做了很多相关工作。人们反馈说他们的进步非常大，并且已经获得了面试机会。所以如果你有面试，并且欢迎额外的技能辅导和自信心提升，请查看“有抱负的心理学家”会员计划。好的，在上半部分，我们查看了Clearinghouse网站提供的往年统计数据，所以
last but not least we're looking at the people who are currently as i record this first year trainee clinical psychologists they would have started applying autumn 2021 to start in September 2022. So that time around, there were 1,155 places, funded places available. That was a 17.97% increase on places, so not quite as much of an increase as last year. But there was only a 2.44% increase on applicants at 4,655. So the success rate there was 25%. So yeah, last year things were looking good. You might on paper have thought, oh, things are heading in a really positive direction. But the early stats that seem to be coming through from individual courses is that people have received complete spikes in the numbers of people applying. And certainly some of the people I really would have expected to be getting shortlisted for interview were told, no, thanks, not yet.
最后但同样重要的是，我们来看看那些在我录制这期节目时，正处于第一年的临床心理学实习生。他们是在2021年秋季申请，于2022年9月入学的。那一次，有1155个资助名额。名额增加了17.97%，增长幅度不如去年。但申请人数仅增加了2.44%，达到4655人。所以那里的成功率是25%。所以是的，去年情况看起来不错。你从纸面上看可能会认为，哦，事情正朝着非常积极的方向发展。但从各个课程传出的早期统计数据来看，申请人数出现了激增。当然，一些我本以为会被列入面试名单的人被告知“不，谢谢，还不是时候”。
Keep trying. And so, yes, what's going on really is what I'm thinking about today. And we will, of course, I will come back to have another look at the stats for this year and come back to talk about that but I guess some of my thoughts were well have we done really well in kind of inclusion and for people who are thinking maybe the pandemic effect has made them think life's too short or you know maybe now's the time or maybe they're feeling that you know all of the empowerment we've done for age just being a number has made people come back to earlier career choices that they might have discounted along the way um or it might be that if you remember in 2020 health education england announced um quite spontaneously on the day the Clinical Psychologist Collective was published, thanks for that HEE, it meant that had to do a swift rewrite of including a few more
继续努力。所以，是的，我今天真正思考的是到底发生了什么。当然，我会回来再次查看今年的统计数据并进行讨论。但我的一些想法是，我们在包容性方面做得很好吗？或者对于那些认为疫情效应让他们觉得人生苦短的人来说，或者现在是时候了，或者他们觉得我们为“年龄只是一个数字”所做的赋能，让人们回到了他们曾经放弃的早期职业选择，或者可能是因为，如果你还记得，2020年英国健康教育局（HEE）在《临床心理学家集体》出版当天突然宣布——感谢HEE，这意味着我不得不迅速重写并增加了一些
chapters, that they were not going to be funding people who'd already had Health Education England funding within the last two years. So they did do a bit of a u-turn on that and they delayed it by two years but by my reckoning this means that the current year is the last year for a while where you'll be able to apply if you have had health education england funding before so that could well be why but i would love your thoughts on this let me know what you think um also would love it if you come and follow me on tiktok and instagram i'm trying to do really hard in growing my um audience there um so yeah please do come and follow me like connect on all those good places um i'm dr marianne trent and uh yeah just be part of my world come and rate and review the podcast on apple podcast too
章节——他们将不再资助那些在过去两年内已经获得过英国健康教育局资助的人。所以他们确实对此做了一些反转，推迟了两年。但据我估计，这意味着今年是未来一段时间内，如果你之前获得过英国健康教育局资助，还能申请的最后一年。所以这很可能是原因。但我很想听听你们对此的看法，请告诉我你们怎么想。另外，如果你们能关注我的TikTok和Instagram我会很高兴，我正在努力增加那里的受众。所以，请一定要关注我，在所有这些好的平台上与我联系。我是Marianne Trent博士，是的，成为我世界的一部分。也请在Apple Podcast上为我的播客评分和评论。
and i will look forward to catching up with you very soon. Take care. Being Qualified is the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Drenth. My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become clinical psychologists. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there, and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself.
我期待很快与你们交流。保重。《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我是Marianne Trent博士。我叫Yana，是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。成为临床心理学家的途径之多让我感到惊讶，没有完美的途径，这让我充满信心，觉得我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。
So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。